okay let's spend some time today talking
about Medicare for all Medicare for all
is becoming a bigger and bigger part of
the 2020 Democratic primary it rightly
so I mean it makes sense this is one of
the biggest issues how are we going to
pay for health care how are we going to
organize health care and there are now
lots of inaccurate things that are being
said about Medicare for all proposals
and there are lots of inaccuracy also
about allegations about the positions of
different candidates around Medicare for
all so what I want to do today and I
hope that this will be useful and
understood in the good faith that I'm
presenting it I want to go through the
bad arguments against Medicare for all
but I also want to bring up the more
serious and sober critiques that are the
areas in which we should be focused
because these are the stronger
criticisms of the proposal so to set the
stage generally if you're already
triggered because I might say something
about Medicare for all is not perfect
you've got to come back to the real
world there is no political proposal
that is perfect or without caveat or
risks or liabilities this is the world
we live in every everything has the
other side of the ledger everything is
risk versus reward
everything is opportunity versus
liability and what we want to figure out
is what proposal or plan is on balance
of the best and most efficient when it
comes to health care for delivering the
best and highest quality and most
available care at the lowest cost we
shouldn't be afraid in serious adult
conversations about discussing the pros
and cons of any policy even a policy
that we think is the best one or better
than the status quo and in fact I would
make a further argument we want we need
to be prepared for when people argue
against Medicare for all we need to be
able to identify these are the serious
arguments to be discussed versus these
are the silly bad faith ignorant
arguments that aren't really worthy of
forth further expert exploration my
prediction is that most of my audience
understands why I'm doing this and
like it and appreciate it but I do know
that there are people who will attack me
merely for talking about here are
question marks that remain about
medicare-for-all which completely misses
the point so first and foremost bad
critiques of Medicare for all
there are many of these one that comes
off often is the countries that have
programs like Medicare for all have
small populations the u.s. is huge
therefore Medicare for all wouldn't work
in the United States this is a bad
critique of Medicare for all number one
bigger population actually means that
you're spreading the risk across more
people there's no one small group or
people with a particular condition that
can throw off the actuarial realities of
what it costs to cover people you can
make the opposite case that actually the
bigger the risk pool the safer and more
efficient and better priced something
like Medicare for all would be that's
that's a bad argument now secondly you
can also disprove that by counter
example because there are many very
large countries that have nationalized
systems of different kinds Germany has
83 million people their system is not
Medicare for all but it is a system that
that is far better than the one we have
and has elements of Medicare for all
Japan has a hundred and thirty million
people I think you get the point now
that being said you can make the case
that what will make the u.s.
implementation more of a struggle or a
challenge are the large rural areas of
the United States because large rural
areas can be more of a concern in terms
of providing access to health care
services but that's not an issue with
Medicare for all specifically that's an
issue more broadly in a country that has
a lot of rural areas and it has nothing
to do with Medicare for all
second bad argument that we hear about
Medicare for all Medicare for all will
lead to long waits for services and
it'll lead to rationing of care and you
know death panels was one of the phrases
that used to be thrown around we already
have those things there is a shortage of
Dermatologists in much of the u.s. you
sometimes have to wait three or four
months as a new patient to see a
dermatologist in all but what would be
considered like emergency you know you
might have skin cancer it needs to be
looked at right
now there's already rationing in our
system because for-profit insurance
companies are deciding who's covered
what is covered when and how much you
can already see de-facto rationing and
it impacts how people obtain or avail
themselves of care that they would like
to have there will sometimes be weights
and there will sometimes be rationing
under Medicare for all it will be
different than under the current system
but it's not unique to Medicare for all
and it is not a unique criticism of
Medicare for all whatsoever then you get
into the general we can't afford it
that's a terrible criticism because we
can't afford our current system if the
barometer for affordability is people
can get the care that would be medically
suggested at a price they can afford
we already have a problem with
affordability affording Medicare for all
is a question of political will it's a
question of deciding what kind of a
system are we going to have and deciding
to put in the means to pay for it now
there also will talk more about cost in
a moment there are also just really dumb
criticisms of Medicare for all like it's
communism these aren't remotely serious
I'm not even going to waste your time
with that today but just know that if
that's if you hear those words in a
critique of Medicare for all
it's not a serious critique so let's now
get to what are the more important and
sensible critiques of Medicare for all
we all want to know what these are so
that we can be prepared seriously I hope
people understand what I'm doing here
I'm not attacking Medicare for all
despite the following critiques it may
still be the best system but this is how
serious people evaluate important
proposals we figure out what are the
strongest arguments against it and then
can we still defend this as the best
policy in light of those arguments does
it stand up to scrutiny as remaining the
best plan
first of all just accepting that
Medicare for all isn't the only way to
get to universal coverage we should all
be doing that's this isn't a criticism
okay it's a reality lots of countries
have universal coverage that people can
afford without Medicare for all or
something that would be
equivalent in that country but with
other plans I've talked about many of
them medicare-for-all could still be the
best could still be the simplest it
could be the cleanest or not but it's
important not to say that
medicare-for-all is the only way to
achieve health care for everyone because
there are many examples from around the
world that are different second the idea
that costs will go down for every one or
almost everyone that is a possible truth
it is possible that you can structure
medicare for all so that cost goes down
for most people but if you look at
serious analyses you will see that in
order for cost to go down for most
people you need either to justify
drastically reducing what healthcare
costs per person in the United States
beyond just what the bureaucracy adds to
the cost I'll get to that momentarily or
you need a more modest plan in terms of
what's covered and I'll explain that now
this is not my opinion if you look at
the work of the Urban Institute which is
left-leaning
they say that to do exactly what Bernie
wants to do overall health care spending
might actually go up I'm just the
messenger here if you do what Bernie
wants to do in terms of Taxation level
but with more modest covered benefits
then the cost might go down for most
people now this is not an attack let's
be adults no system is perfect there are
many ways to set up a plan there are
left-leaning analyses that say it is not
as cut and dry as Bernie's numbers make
it out to be
now that's okay it might still be the
best proposal we have and it would
definitely be better than what we have
right now but we're doing an analysis so
let's stick with this issue of cost for
now the argument is right now we have
all these different costs we've got
employee paid health insurance premiums
employer contributions to healthcare
premiums that many employers you've got
your co-pays some people have
coinsurance you have an annual
deductible you have to meet there is a
maximum yearly out-of-pocket
it all adds up and the idea is Medicare
for all gets rid of all of that stuff
and it gets replaced with a payroll
that is shared by employees and
employers and overall the cost comes
down this is in total a claim that has
some controversy around it even when you
look at nonpartisan and even
left-leaning economists it's possible
that that's the way it would work it's
not guaranteed okay
there are dense economic papers which I
encourage you to read from good
economists for example Robert poling
from the University of Massachusetts who
has consulted for Bernie Sanders who
says the truth is we don't yet have all
the details to say for sure that the
middle class is definitely going to save
let me again be clear costs might go up
slightly they would cover more so it
might still be a trade we want to make
and it still could be the best proposal
for most people but serious economists
say it's a little early we don't really
have the data to say that costs are
gonna go down for almost everyone the
way that Bernie and Warren and others
have been saying it's not an attack or a
defense on any candidate this is just
the reality about these proposals let's
do one more thing related to the cost
piece Bernie has said you raise the
money from an employee tax and an
employer tax the employer tax is only
going to hit companies that have
payrolls of two million or more per year
if you look at that economists generally
believe that that tax that the employers
pay will be passed along to workers as
either wage cuts or will delay future
wage increases or will lead to companies
maybe not hiring as many people that
doesn't mean it's a bad plan that's
something that economists say is not
being accounted for in the broader
economic impact of the proposals that's
a serious question now again this might
still be the best plan but we don't want
to pretend that every question is
answered by the proposals that we have
so far now there's one other detail
Bernie and Elizabeth Warren haven't made
clear who counts as middle-class a big
part of what they say is middle-class
total costs will go down
we need to know who counts as middle
class in order to evaluate that so far
we haven't gotten that doesn't mean
anything's dishonest doesn't mean
anything is under the you know untoward
but we need to know that next
aside from who pays there's the issue of
total cost and this is what I alluded to
earlier there are left-wing economists
serious economists who say proposals for
Medicare for all are drastically
understating the cost to deliver care a
one example is an economist named
Kenneth Thorpe he was hired remember one
Vermont was going to do state
single-payer he's not a right-wing bomb
thrower he was hired by Vermont to help
implement state single-payer which
ultimately didn't happen Thorpe has said
that as proposed if we look at Bernie's
2016 Medicare for all plan which is very
similar to the one we have today 71
percent of households overall who
currently have private insurance might
end up actually paying more in total
when you account for the tax increases
now they may have better access they may
have more covered services we still
might want to do it but the claim that
everybody's costs will go down this
left-wing economist says there is a
question mark around that that's just
one analysis but it's an important one
and it's really important to understand
where the discrepancy comes from Thorpe
says that Bernie's plan the numbers
Bernie uses they change out when they
change out from a private insurance
system to a single-payer system they
assume that our per person health care
spending will drop to the healthcare
spending per person in countries like
Canada and Australia this is an
assumption that may never happen and it
could take a long time what I mean by
that is Canada spends forty eight
percent less per person in the United
States on health care Australia spends
56 percent less per person than in the
United States part of that discrepancy
is the bureaucracy built into the system
that we have and when you get a more
efficient system for paying like
Medicare for all there will be a savings
but there has not been a good answer to
why are we assuming total costs will go
down to what they are in in Australia
and Canada because there are many other
reasons including just how things are
priced here in the United States that
will keep costs higher and that throws
the numbers of most of these
medicare-for-all proposals out of line
now you can make the case once it's a
single-payer system the government is
going to be able to negotiate costs of
all services all the way down to what
Canada and Australia have that is a bit
optimistic by serious analyses so like
that's a question mark so does this mean
Medicare for all is bad no it doesn't
does this mean Medicare for all is worse
than what we have now definitely not it
would be better does it mean we should
abandon Medicare for all as a platform
absolutely not especially because
remember a lot of Democrats already
opposed it and it's going to be a
negotiation no matter what happens in
November of 2020 but we need to
understand the details because there are
good faith
questions about Medicare for all that
smart people on the Left are bringing up
and they're being brought up because we
want the best system we want to
anticipate what arguments could be made
against it and we want to be able to
distinguish bad arguments like the US
has too many people for this to work
terrible argument or it's communism not
even an argument versus listen if you
look at the cost assumptions and most of
these proposals they seem idealistic and
potentially beyond what the facts
support that's the important thing here
and if we go through that we might still
decide Medicare for all is the best
system or we might say Medicare for all
is a great system that has these
problems and here is another system not
the lame public option but serious other
ways of getting to universal coverage
that have other issues but resolve some
of the issues of Medicare for all this
is how we have to think through these
serious problems and I think that's why
it's worth taking the time to go through
it let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show